мене звати бобенко Максим Я народився і
проживаю в селі тупичів Чернігівській
області Цього літа я придумав проект щоб
зробити своє селище ще краще Це був
проект пляж я хотів зробити найкращий
пляж в світі біля озера ковалівське я
придумав цей проект намалював його
запросив допомагати своїх друзів і також
до нас
підключилися керівництво спиртзаводу
ковалівсь
і його робітники яким ми дуже вдячні
ми об'єдналися і
побудували прибиральню туалети місце де
можна переодягатися все пофарбували
повністю якщо ви хочете щось покращити в
своєму селі то
починайте прямо зараз тому що Хто буде
робити як
не than